>> From the library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Now for what we are really all
here for, Holly Robinson Peete.
I'm so excited.
She is a force and a
woman of many talents.
Of course, we all know
her as an actress,
a singer, an author, of course.
She has been in the entertainment
industry for most of her life
and found success in hit movies
and shows like 21 Jump Street,
and of course, my personal
favorites,
Hanging with Mr. Cooper
and For Your Love.
But there are a few other talents
that she touts on her Instagram
and I think we should, they're
really highly important.
First, mom of four, of course,
she is a resolution seeker,
a philanthropist, and then a few
that I don't think we
know too much about.
Plumber, Uber driver,
and dog interpreter.
And I guess as a mom of four
you do what must be done.
And she's doing what must be done.
Her philanthropic efforts
through her
and her husband's organization
Holly Rod Foundation have won,
not only won awards for
compassionate service,
but have placed a national spotlight
on two causes very personal
to the Peete family,
Parkinson's disease and Autism.
Holly Robinson Peete is
an award winning author
and has won an NAACP Image Award
for her outstanding literary work
in her children's book entitled
My Brother Charlie about autism
from the sibling's
perspective co-authored
by her daughter Ryan
Elizabeth Peete.
Her latest book Same
But Different Teen Life
on the Autism Express paints an
important story of hope for teens
and families living with
autism, and lets us all see
that everybody's unique
rhythm is worth dancing to.
The book was co-written with her
twin children Ryan Elizabeth Peete
and R.J Tweet Peete
who was diagnosed
with autism at the age of three.
Holly Robinson Peete continues
to do what must be done and more
to inspire teens and families living
with autism, and we appreciate her
and her family for being a symbol
of hope and light for us all.
So without further ado, please help
me welcome Holly Robinson Peete.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much.
What a great introduction.
Can you come back home
with me to L.A.
and just introduce me
like that every morning?
[ Laughter ]
>> Can you imagine if
you woke up every morning
and you were introduced
like that to your kids?
[ Laughter ]
>> That'd be fabulous.
I am-let me find my clicker.
Wala. I am so excited
to be here today.
What an amazing festival.
It's my first time here
and I absolutely love it.
Thank you to all of you who
came to this presentation today.
As many of you know, if
you didn't know before,
you know I am a mom
first, a mom of four,
and I have a son with special needs.
And it's been pretty
much the narrative
of my life for the last 18 years.
And there's nothing more fulfilling
than when you have a situation
that happens to you that
can be quite devastating
and then you're able to
eventually see it as a blessing
because you're able to touch others.
It's a really tremendous feeling.
So, I'm just absolutely
thrilled to be able to be here
and share my story with you.
Oh, OK. So, it works.
Ya'll, you're listening that's
the first thing you're just
so excited that the clicker works.
[ Laughter ]
>> So, My Brother-we're
going to talk about Same
But Different, which
is our new book.
My Brother Charlie is a
book I'm super proud of.
I came to Scholastic many years
ago, and I pitched this book.
And I went to several publishers,
and they really didn't get it.
They really didn't get the
pervasive, prevalence of autism
and they just didn't understand.
And certainly in communities
of color
where our children our
diagnosed two to five years later
than other children, it was really
important to have a book like this,
especially from the
sibling's perspective.
And so these are my twins.
Aww, yeah, they're-- they're
18, so the aww factor is gone.
[ Laughter ]
Aww. But back then, it was
aww, so cute, born in '97.
This is my dad.
So many of you of a certain age will
remember my dad was the original
Gordon on Sesame Street.
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
He is my inspiration for reading,
for-I mean the man could tell a
story like you couldn't imagine,
and he wrote so many stories
as Gordon on Sesame Street.
He was the original Gordon.
So that was like '69 to '72.
And he was an amazing man, awesome
writer, wrote for everything
from Sanford and Son, The
Cosby Show, the Waltons.
I mean he's a guy who really had a
lot to contribute to this television
and entertainment, but was diagnosed
with Parkinson's disease at only 45.
Yeah, it was deep because
it was in the 80's.
And I was just a freshman
in college,
and I didn't know what Parkinson's
was, and we didn't have the internet
and Google yet and
you know Mohammed Ali.
We just didn't have a whole lot
and it was kind of a scary time.
But through him it led
me to a life of service.
And then through our books we
were able to serve even more.
So, here's some more cute
pictures of the twins.
Oh, I love this picture
because you can tell
when R.J. was just
diagnosed around this time,
Ryan was really there for him.
You know, she always turned
his frown upside down,
like we used to say.
And she's always had his back.
We got our diagnosis in 1999.
We call it the never day because
we were told he was never going
to be so many things.
This pediatrician just
basically, bless her heart,
decided she was going to
give us a laundry list
of what he would never
do at three years old.
So, it's very, you know, it comes
with a lot of audacity to be able
to tell a parent that your
kid will never say I love you,
never do a whole bunch of things
that he eventually ended up doing.
So, I want to quickly play this
little quick video that Ryan,
his twin sister, and his
little brothers made.
So, that's why it's a
little bit, it looks young.
It's not professional.
But it just gives a very good first
person narrative of who R.J. is.
[ Music ]
>> My name is Rodney Jackson Peete.
Some people call me R.J.,
but I like Rodney better.
When I was three, the doctor
told my mom and dad I had autism.
Autism means I have a
brain that is different.
I did not really speak
too well until I was six.
I did not really make friends.
I cried a lot.
I felt weird in my body.
People don't understand my world.
It was hard.
Can you imagine feeling something
but not being able to say it.
Mom and dad did everything
for me to get me better.
Thankfully, they could do that.
I wish other kids do some
things I could do now.
A lot of families do not have enough
money to help their kids get better.
That makes me sad.
I wish there was a place where you
could go and not pay and get help.
I like the NBA and MLB.
I could tell you all the
players names on every team,
but I really have a hard
time making friends.
The doctor said I would
never play team sports.
>> Wrong. Never give up.
>> The doctor said I
would never make friends.
>> Wrong.
>> You got to have hope.
>> The doctor said I would
never say I love you on my own.
But I do all the time.
My twin sister wrote
a book about autism.
I'm so proud of her.
My mom and I wrote
a song about autism.
Wanna hear it?
I may have autism, but
autism doesn't have me.
[ Applause ]
>> So, that's R.J.
So that's R.J. and you
can see he's a sweet kid,
and he didn't have
language for so long.
And we really wanted to use his
example to give other people hope.
Because that's really what we didn't
have when we got our diagnosis.
We wrote this book for many
reasons, very obvious reasons being
that autism is very
prevalent right now,
and wanted to promote awareness.
But in the end, it
was really about hope.
It was really about peddling
hope, making sure that people
that were given the diagnosis
that we were given can know
that our kids can eventually
become part of society
and be loved and have talents.
And we're always talking
about what they can't do,
but we wanted to show
what they can do.
So, one of the reasons
that we started,
I started becoming an author is
because I went to school one day
and my daughter Ryan said, "No one
knows at school what autism is, Mom.
So, we got to tell them,
because no one knows."
This was like third
grade or fourth grade.
And so, I said, "Well, Dad and
I we'll go down to the school
and have a conversation."
She was like, "That's OK.
We don't need you to
go down to school."
[ Laughter ]
[laughter] So, I said, "No, Ryan,
you have to understand like we need
to come down there and
have a conversation.
You don't have to be
in the classroom,
but we need to explain it."
And so she gave us the bullet points
on what to say and what not to say.
She said, obviously,
don't embarrass us.
She said, make it a
level playing field
and accentuate the
positive, a sense of humor.
You know, the first thing
that we said to this group
of fourth graders was, what do you
do well, what don't you do well?
And one kid was like, "I
really play football well.
But I don't read good."
And another kid said you
know, "I'm great at math.
But I don't know how
to play soccer."
And I said, "Well, R.J.
can tell you the names
of every single president
and vice president.
He can tell you the name
of every single player
on every sport league that exists.
But he has a hard time
making friends."
And it was amazing, like this
fog just lifted over them,
and it was pretty awesome.
Autism in America is out
of control quite frankly.
There are so many kids
diagnosed with this disorder.
It's very mysterious.
We didn't know about it
until we were impacted by it.
And the more we talk about it,
the more we write books about it,
the more the stigma goes away.
And that's another goal of ours.
Just, these are-now
R.J. is growing up now.
He's getting hair on his
face, and, yeah mommy's trying
to cut it while he's sleeping.
[ Laughter ]
Trying to shave him.
I really do try and shave him
while he's sleeping cause.
And he's just been awesome.
So we decided we would do a
reality show because why not?
[ Applause ]
Because
So when I pitched this reality
show to my family, I said,
"It's not going to be like-don't
worry there won't be anybody
throwing drinks in anyone's face.
And there's no fights.
But I felt like just like with our
books and going on different shows,
I wanted to continue the narrative.
And I felt like it would be really
helpful for people to see us
in our lives and how
we rally around R.J.,
and just you know,
we're married 21 years.
We're not a perfect family at all.
But we felt like it would be
interesting to show our journey.
And so we're in our-we're about to
start our second season in February.
We're on the Oprah Winfrey Network.
The show's called For Peete's Sake.
And I just bought a couple clips.
And this just is really,
you know, obviously,
we're here at a book fest, this
is not a television convention,
but I wanted to share a couple
of clips because I wanted you
to see sort of, this is an
extension of our work as authors.
>> When R.J. and I were three years
old and he was first diagnosed
with autism, he was having a
lot of trouble communicating.
I'd almost be his voice and I'd
often speak for him at times.
I've always been in R.J.'s corner.
>> Go to U.S.C.
>> You want me to go to U.S.C.?
>> Yeah go to your dad's old school.
>> Whatever she wants to do, I'll
go with it, and I'll support her.
But, I want her to go to U.S.C.
so she's close to me a lot.
[ Music ]
>> Well, she went to N.Y.U.
She didn't go to U.S.C.
[ Laughter ]
So so much for being close.
We took her last month
with cameras in tow.
She was a little mortified that
she would be the freshman checking
in with cameras following her.
But it was New York,
honey, nobody even noticed.
[ Laughter ]
No one even noticed.
And here's another clip.
>> Are you kidding
me with that photo?
>> So that's a lead picture.
You modeled it like
an absolute champion.
[ Music ]
There's that one.
>> Oh my god.
>> It's over.
>> Are you [beep]-excuse me.
[ Laughter ]
>> It happens.
That was when we were trying to
find a job for R.J. You know?
Where's he going to work?
What's he's going to do?
How's he going to self-advocate?
How's he going to make
his own money?
And everyone had their own input
about what would be best for him.
I wanted him to work
at the bird store,
the pet store because
he likes pets and birds.
And so he went down
there and tried that.
My husband wanted him
to work at Wich Wich.
I don't know if you
guys have Wich Wich.
It's like a Subway sandwich place.
And we knew the manager
because my husband was worried
that he wanted someone
to shadow him.
My mom was like, "My
grandson is fine.
He needs to be a model."
And so she took him
to a modeling agency.
And then those were the pictures.
And we were like, "Oh, dang.
Like"--
[ Laughter ]
-- "he could really do this."
And so that was last year.
And then I'll get to
what ended up happening.
I will spoil it for you,
not for you, but for you,
yeah for you, I'll spoil it for you.
[ Laughter ]
And then here's another clip.
>> My hope for children with autism
is to know how special they are.
When I was like three the
doctor told me I had autism
and I couldn't speak, but when I got
a little older I started to speak,
I started to talk more, and
now I can't stop talking.
[ Laughter ]
>> When R.J. was diagnosed with
autism there was a lady sitting
across from us that told
us he would never be able
to speak, let alone make a speech.
To see him be an autism
advocate is so awesome.
I mean these moments are things
we never thought we would ever see
him do.
[ Music ]
>> So For Peete's Sake has been an
awesome tool, an awesome extension,
an awesome way to spread what is
going on in the autism community
as these kids grow
up and become adults.
Because we always think of autism
as you know, three year old,
a two year old, or a five year old.
But, they grow up and they
need to have relationships.
Where are they going to live?
What kind of communities
are they going to have?
So, it's been really wonderful
to have this extension.
And the books, especially Same
But Different really chronicles
this transition or the transition
from middle school to high school.
You know, what that's like.
How Ryan advocated for him.
How hard it was for him to navigate
the things like social media,
and girlfriends, and proms,
and just all the high school
and middle school things that are
difficult for a typical child,
let alone a kid that's
socially is disconnected.
And so, Same But Different
is a book I'm super proud
of because we were able
to really tell the story
in such a beautiful way, and I'm so
proud that Andrea, my editor is here
because she was so, it was so
important that we tell it in a way
that connected with a
families in an authentic way
because it's a nuanced journey.
It's not something that
is very easy to classify.
And we all say in the autism
community, if you've met one kid
with autism, you've just
met one kid with autism.
There's all different.
And so this was, Same But Different
was a sort of collaboration
of our journey plus other people's
journeys that we met along the way.
OK. Oh, wait.
Hold on. What did I do?
Hold on. I knew I was going
to have a clip problem.
>> My hope for children with autism.
>>Sorry, never mind.
Hold on. Here we go.
[ Music ]
Which one is this?
>> Anytime you have someone-- -
>> Oh yeah.
>>-- that doesn't really understand
you, they're not really going
to know how to love you because
they don't know who you are.
I don't want you to feel
sad about not having 25,
30 friends because you
you only really need one
or two good friends, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Mom has Auntie Terry.
>> I have Wonder.
>> You have Wonder.
>> He always look out for me.
>> Would Wonder ever put you in a
bad position where you were either
in harms way or you did
something inappropriate?
He would never do that.
>> No.
>> That's a real friend.
[ Music ]
>> So in Same But Different we
talk all-we explore the themes
of friends and friendship.
The hardest thing for kids on the
spectrum to do is have friends.
It's a very difficult thing.
My son went through pretty much all
of elementary school
with no friends.
He still struggles with this theme.
And in that scene, you know, he sort
of still haunted by an experience
in middle school where these
boys made him do something
and say inappropriate
things to a girl.
And then they had to
restrain me to keep me
from going down to the school.
[ Laughter ]
[laughter] Because I was just-I
needed him to process this
and walk through this on his own.
But, he learned from it.
He learned the value and
the meaning of friendship.
But he still, at almost 19,
struggles with this theme.
So, that was part of what
we talk about in the book
in several chapters,
and also what we talk
about on the show as
he moves forward.
So, here's the spoiler alert.
Because you all came I'm going to
share this information with you,
so act like you didn't
see it in February.
But the cool thing is that because
of a scene in the whole theme
of finding R.J. a job
in For Peete's Sake,
someone from the Los Angeles Dodgers
baseball team reached out and saw us
on the show, because he
saw the show, and he said,
"Does R.J. really need a job
because I think we have
something here for him."
And so we were like, "Yeah.
I mean, it was real.
He really is looking for a gig."
And so they said, "Bring him
down to the Dodgers Stadium."
So me and Rodney bought him
down like it was his
first day of kindergarten.
And we bought him down there
and we literally thought we
were just having a meeting,
and they sent him down to the
equipment room, they dressed him up,
and now he works at the
clubhouse at the Dodgers.
And so now-
[ Applause ]
-- he is-
-- got this great gig.
[ Applause ]
It is unbelievable this job for
him and what it has done for him.
I get the chills just
thinking about it.
And the best part of that picture-I
can't zoom in with this clicker,
is the look on his twin
sister's face in the background.
She is so proud of him, and was so
concerned about her leaving going
to New York from L.A., leaving him
alone, and now he has something.
Because I have to tell you when she
got the whole process of college,
it really sort of is that reminder
that, oh yeah, he is different,
he's not going to college
like she is.
And so for him to have
something cool for himself.
But this job has given him such
a sense of, I mean he walks
out with his hands on his hips
and he swaggers, he just swagger.
And so last night at the
Dodgers I just tweeted something
about the Dodgers, like
it was the end of the,
it's the end of the regular season,
and I said, you know thank you
to the Dodgers for embracing
our family, ya da da da da.
And one of the Dodgers subtweeted
me and he wrote, "Thank you for R.J.
because he makes the clubhouse,
like he gives us energy.
He's better for us than
I think we are for him."
Yeah it was pretty awesome.
So, that's-listen, he comes
in at midnight after working
because he gets there
three hours before the team
and he leaves two hours,
two or three hours after.
I mean, it is a job.
And he comes home, I mean, the
only thing he doesn't do is go
to the fridge for a beer.
He comes in with his lunch box.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you know, he's like
[laughter]-and he wants to talk.
You know he wants to talk
about his experience.
And so you know if
it's midnight or 1:00,
you know when you're sleeping you
can feel somebody standing over you,
you're just like, I'm like-
[ Laughter ]
"Yes, R.J."
He goes, "Mom, can you wake up."
Now, this is a kid who couldn't
talk before, so I am obliged
to wake up and talk to him.
[ Laughter ]
[laughter] So.
[ Applause ]
Yeah. So, I mean I
can't what can you say?
No, I don't want to talk?
So-but he shares so much more.
He's connected so much more.
And this is a blessing for us, OK?
We are a privileged family.
Listen, the elf in the room,
you know Rodney played football.
I've been on t.v. all these
years, and we have fought for him.
We are very resourceful.
But what-the Dodgers hiring him
means to me and the bigger picture,
not just for my kid, is
these kids are hirable.
That they can work
in big corporations,
and that everyone needs
to make room for them
because they have amazing skills.
So-oh, what is that?
OK, well-that slipped in there.
[ Laughter ]
That's from my 50th birthday party.
How'd that get in there?
[ Laughter ]
OK. All right.
Bobby, was that you?
No, you did a great job.
Thank you so much.
So, I wanted to rush through
this because I wanted to get
through to a Q and A. I
really-it's really important
for me-I actually get more from
you-like the Dodgers with R.J.-I get
so much from hearing from you and
the things you're experiencing,
so please if you have any
questions, I would love to hear
from you, comments, anything.
I think-how much time do we have?
Ten minutes?
So, if you would like to come up
and the microphones are right here.
Please feel free.
And you can ask any questions.
You can ask about 21
Jump Street and-
[ Laughter ]
-- anything you want.
Yes, mahm?
>> I'm a teacher in a high school
and I run a program
for kids with autism.
So many of my parents find it
hard to accept them as they are
and think all my kids
are going to college.
Not all the kids I teach
are going to college,
are going to go to college.
How did you come to accept
R.J. for who he is and not say,
he's going to college
like everybody else.
How did you do that?
>> Well, you know I'll use
the example of my husband
because he was deeply, deeply
steeped in denial for many years
to the point where I really, really
had to say to him, you know what,
you can go, because I have
to get this kid going,
and you are holding me back because
you're not able to accept who he is.
There's a moment in everyone's life
where you realize you can't control,
you can't control things,
and things that are
out of control you have
to make the best of.
I think with R.J. and with any
kid who is-who has a difficulty
in experiencing life, I always say
I can't-I wouldn't change my kid
for the world, but I would
change the world for my kid,
or I would try to change the world.
So, how about we just
allow them to be different
and think outside the box and try to
give them something that, you know,
stop trying to squeeze them
and put them in our narrative.
So, the conversation of his
twin sister going to college
and he's not going to college
that was a sobering moment
because in my mind I knew it,
but I never really admitted it.
So, I think it's just allowing them
to be who they are and understanding
who they are and coming
into their world.
Thank you so much for the
work that you're doing.
Yes, mahm.
>> Yes, hi.
I'd just like to first of all say,
hi to you because I had-my
father had Parkinson's,
and I also have a 20
year old son with autism.
>> Oh wow.
>> So I think I've gone through a
lot of what you've gone through.
>> Absolutely.
>> My son actually did
make it to college,
but I worry about him
all the time, believe me.
But, I just want to ask you do you
think Parkinson's, not Parkinson's,
autism, they keep saying it gets
diagnosed more and more every year,
do you think we're just diagnosing
it more, or do that many kids just,
is it really that more
than it used to be?
>> I mean my personal feeling, and
everyone has an opinion I'm sure,
but my personal feeling is that
there's some kind of environmental,
there's some kind of
genetic predisposition
that we haven't identified,
and that it's triggered
by some kind of environmental thing.
I do think we're diagnosing it
better but the prevalence is flying
up so high I think
there's some piece of this
that we're not looking
at for some reason.
So yeah, that's just my opinion.
>> Yeah, because I
have an older sister
who they didn't say she had autism
because that was back
in the 50's and 60's.
>> Right.
>> They told my parents she was,
and the termed they used
back then, mentally retarded.
>> Right.
>> Which [inaudible].
Well, thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
Good luck to your son.
Hi.
>> Hi. I'm a middle school special
educator and I want to say thank you
because our general population needs
to see more books like this to know
that everybody's an individual,
and it just gives me
goosebumps, so thank you.
>> Aww, thank you so much.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Yes.
>> Hi.
>> Just FYI, you and I are
besties in my head because-
>> OK.
[ Laughter ]
>>-- because we have
so much in common.
>>Well, we can talk later and maybe-
>> Yeah.
>>-- and make it real.
[ Laughter ]
>> My son is 18, diagnosed at three.
I've been married for 19 years.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> You know, lots of things.
So in my head, we know each other.
>> OK.
[ Laughter ]
>> With that being said, my question
is around sort of what's going
on in the world with being a
black male in this country.
>> Right.
>> My son's 18.
He's autistic.
He's not very verbal.
And so I have to send him
out into the world every day
without those skills, verbal
skills, social skills,
and how to handle stimulus and other
people, and how they perceive him.
>> Correct.
>> You know, how do you, how do you
approach that with your son in terms
of preparing him to be a black
man in this country right now,
and then also have special needs?
>> Well, we did an episode on that
for For Peete's Sake very early
on when we talked about
how do we send our son
out without understanding-and
see you
in the room probably already know
that our kids don't
process social cues
in the same way as
a typical kid would.
So, the idea of put your hands
up or do this or do that.
So we ran him through drills.
I mean like drills.
You know, over and over again.
And he was awesome with it.
You know? He was like, "OK, Mom.
OK, Mom, I got it."
Because we'd been doing this
with him for many years.
The problem is when he comes back
and he says, "OK, I just watched
that video and he complied like you
told me, but he still got shot."
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's rough.
I'm like, "Hold on.
Go talk to your dad."
[ Laughter ]
So, these are issues
that we're dealing with,
not just with our special kids but
with all kids, all of our kids.
And so we just keep talking to them.
We keep the dialogue open.
We keep talking them.
What I don't want are my
kids to become cynical..
>> Right.
>> I want them to feel like
they can call the police.
They can connect with the police.
You know I don't want them to have
this us against them mentality.
So I really try to bridge that
gap, but I want to keep it real
with them at the same time.
And they need to understand.
And I think on the clip, I wish
I had thought I had that clip,
but on the clip where I talk
to my son about his interaction
with police, I said, what do
you do if they come to you.
And he said, "Reach into my pocket,
and get my phone, and
call my mommy."
I was like, "No, no, no, no, no."
>> [laughter]
[ Laughter ]
>> That's not what you do.
So, but these are the
things that we get
from having conversations
and continuing.
Now my son has verbal
abilities but he still stumbles
and he still-a little bit.
If you have a nonverbal child
or a verbally challenged
child it is really difficult.
It's hard to relax.
So I understand, but just
keep having the conversations.
OK, that's [inaudible].
>> Thank you.
>>[laughter] Nice meeting you.
Yes, mahm.
>> That's actually my friend too.
[laughter]
>> Oh, OK.
[ Laughter ]
>> So, we're all in the same club.
>> But I actually have three kids
and two, my two boys have autism.
>> Oh wow.
>> So, I have a 10 year old,
who's moderate to severe.
He's not really-he will say words.
He has echolalia, repeating words.
And he has his little ACC device.
He's learning that.
And then my 12, soon to be
13 year old has Aspergers.
>> Wow.
>> So he talks as much as R.J. now.
[laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> And my thing is-because I have a
slew of questions, but the one thing
for me is how do I stop apologizing
for the youngest one
you know outburst
in church and things like that.
Or how do I stop being like when
people are looking at my kids
as if they're having a fit
and they're terrible kids,
and I want to look at
them and be like, what?
[laughter]
>> Right.
>> What are you looking at?
>> Well that just comes
from advocating because,
and that's literally one of the
reasons why we wrote these books.
We want the world to be a
little bit more tolerant
of special kids, right?
So when I'm in the supermarket
or my kid's acting out, you know,
I mean your first, the
first thought is, oh,
that kid needs to be
disciplined more.
How come you let-can't
you control your child?
If I had a nickel for every time I
heard, can't you control your child,
especially on an airplane
because R.J. used
to just push the flight
attendant button.
[ Laughter ]
Ding, ding, ding.
Over and over again.
Kicking the seat.
But more than your regular
child that would kick the seat.
I mean, and at first I was
angry about the judgment, right?
But then I realized, you know, not
everybody knows what's happening.
And they don't-I didn't know
what autism was before I was
diagnosed-had the diagnosis,
so I needed to be more
compassionate towards people
that don't understand.
And I find that you get a lot
more, "Oh, I didn't know."
So when he was kicking the
seat, "My son has autism
and he kind of can't help it."
"I'll move over here.
I'll try to hold his legs."
Or I try to book a seat
that has a bulk head
so that there's no, you know?
But, it's a tough world out there.
And you know, your son that is
dealing with, your youngest son
who with the outburst
at church whatever,
we have to just keep enlightening
the community, and letting them know
that he's special and
that's what he does.
Now your older child, the
Asperger thing is very interesting
because these are kids that
quote u unquote don't look
like they have autism, and
they're actually quite brilliant,
and they're super verbal, but
they're socially disconnected.
They can't look you in
the eye and make a friend.
So, it's hard, and those are
difficult things to try and explain.
But the more we talk about it,
the more conversations we have
the more people will understand.
Good luck with you babies.
>> Thank you.
>> OK. Hi.
>> Hi. I'm a part of an organization
called Best Buddies and we work
with pairing children with different
abilities with other children.
And so I was just wondering if
you had any advice on like how
to explain autism to someone who
doesn't have experience with it?
>> That's a really good
question and I love Best Buddies.
I love doing work with them.
Such a great organization.
And especially when they start
working with kids with autism.
It's just a great organization.
You know I just explain autism
as you know being just different.
And you know, not to push the
book, the same but different.
You know, it's just, there's a world
that they have and we just have
to stop and come into that world.
And I think that kids with
autism can teach you so much
about who you are, and
teach you patience.
But, as I said earlier, if
you've met one kid with autism,
you've only met one kid with autism.
I would just say, just
you know, stop,
be patient, try to learn about it.
And also try to give back
to a family that's experiencing
something like autism.
So, for instance, it maybe
that they just need you
to babysit their other
kids for a day.
It maybe they need something.
It's hard to put in words because
autism is such a wide spectrum,
but the fact that you're working
with Best-how old are you?
>> I'm 15.
>> And you work with Best Buddies?
>> Yeah. My high school
has a chapter.
>> Oh, that's awesome.
Well, we need more 15
year olds like you.
[ Applause ]
>> -- to work with-
-- to get the word out because
that's really what it is.
It's getting the word out,
especially with younger kids.
I think we have one more question.
Time for one more question.
By the way, if you all are in line
and I see there are some great
people in line, please feel free
to either find me on
my HollyRod website.
I answer all the questions.
Or, on social media,
I'm at HollyRPeete
on all social media channels.
And today if you hashtag
National Book Fest,
I will respond directly to you.
Yes, mahm.
>> I just wanted to say I have three
kids, two twins, a boy and girl,
but my daughter is the
one who has autism.
And so, one of the questions,
or I think one of the things
that is not always
addressed or looked
at is the impact on
the other children.
>> Yes.
>> And how you deal with
not letting it be always
about the child with the autism.
>> Right.
>> I wanted to know in your
family how you dealt with that.
>> Really go out of our
way to schedule time one
on one with the other kids.
I mean, just we have to
have that one on one time
where it's just you and them.
And so your child with
autism is not present.
You have that relationship.
There's that special thing
that you do with that other,
with that sibling so that they
don't feel-I mean my daughter,
my youngest kids used to say,
"Boy, I wish I had autism,
you'd pay more attention to me."
You know. I mean, those are
the things that you hear.
That's real.
You know, but the reality is
you have to make that connection
and make that, carve that
time out in any way you can,
even if it's just going to the park
or just taking a quick field trip.
And just one more question
because we have a-
>> It's not a question, we
just wanted to say hello.
We follow you.
This is my Robert, my R.J.
>> Oh, R.J. Wait Robert is his name?
>> Robert.
>> Hi, Robert.
>> He just wanted to say hello.
We follow you on social media.
We love the show.
>> Just come a little closer.
We can't hear you.
>> So much from watching the show.
So much of our lives mirror yours.
>> Do you all live here locally?
>> No.
>> We're in North Carolina.
>> OK.
>> We're in North Carolina, but
we just want to say thank you
for the inspiration,
you, and R.J., and Ryan,
because he has a sister
Kendall, back-
>> Just a little closer,
we want to hear.
>> 10 year old Kendall back
there who is his protector.
She's his-
>> Are they twins?
>> -- best friend.
They're not.
They're two years apart.
He's 16. But he absolutely
was so excited to get
in here and see you today.
So, thank you.
>> Hey, Robert.
Hi.
[ Applause ]
Thank you for coming.
>> We just wanted to say thank you.
>> I'm signing books at 4:30,
so I hope to see you all there.
Thank you.
This has been awesome.
What's that?
Oh.
>> Line three.
I don't know what that
means, but line three.
[ Laughter ]
Ya'll you know.
I don't need to know.
Someone will take me there.
But, thank you so much.
This just was a great-I tell
you I get more from you,
and I appreciate just the
energy that you give me,
and I appreciate it so much.
So, thank you all.
See you a little later.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov